bonsoir bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur
ce live spéciale 1 million d'abonnés
pour garder le stage merci à tous de
nous avoir suivis pendant plus d'un an
et merci à brienz tonique brainsonic
pardon de nous prêter ses studios ce
soir on va recevoir l'ensemble des
auteurs de golden moustache alors
n'hésitez pas à continuer à poser vos
questions sur twitter hashtag millions
gm tout de suite on va recevoir ceux qui
ont pris pour emblème un animal des
steppes africaines suri 4
comment on pouvait savoir comment on
allait synchro j'étais comme ça j'étais
ok j'ai tout dit il
ouais merci largement la de l'argent
maintenant sur tout son réseau dans tout
seul
donc je vais voir un tas de questions à
vous poser c'est les internautes qui les
ont posées sur twitter et qui vont
continuer à les poser ce que vous êtes
prêt avec le hashtag avec le malgré tout
sa cinquième tome on est entre nous la
cbi d'un titre des tentations un bide
est ce que quelqu'un vous présentez
suricates avant ou est ce que je me
lance dans cette web ait des gens qui ne
connaissent pas encore je viens
débrouille généralement bien pour le
départ ne devrait pas tarder par top sur
ical sud est sur quatre qui sommes nous
nous étions quatre les nerfs maintenant
ils sont plus que trois teintes attends
je fais la bo en même temps parce qu'il
ya plein de vie non mais ben voilà on
est un groupe d'humoristes maintenant
composé de trois personnes il s'appelle
rafael mais des doigts bien là pour les
planches comme ça et non oui basse et
chant la real en voilà et vincent saly
et voilà on fait des sketches donc sur
golden moustache que vous regardez
activement ses recherches on a de
l'argent maintenant tu en as un plateau
vous devez la télé vous mais je leur
fais gaffe au sérieux
mais voilà on fait des sketches on
essaye d'être rigolo et voilà dans un
esprit humoristique généralement on
essaie d'être surprenant
ça c'est n'importe quoi on a très bien
s'arrêter là ils m'ont fait je veux pas
savoir hier question ces petits boules
qui demande
à ce que la façon dont je l'aï fait
vivre le qui demandent comment se sont
rencontrés et suricates donc la question
qui veut répondre à sa première question
je sais que ça fait vachement bien ok ça
l'est d'autant san rafael c'était au
collège au lycée
collège paul menard on était tous en moi
j'étais en troisième c'est bien pratique
et des vincent était de l'autre côté du
mur est obligé au lycée et on rêvait
d'aller traîner avec vincent du coup se
retrouver dehors pour aller boire les
deux lascars n'a failli jamais dire que
c'est en fait ça c'est donc le truc
inventé pour rendre le truc complètement
fou pour dire que cette femme
s'est tristement en taule
nom n'était auteurs parmi eux on faisait
partie d'une quinzaine une quatorzaine
d'auteur et on s'est rencontré et puis
sont restés quatre individus humanoïdes
afin d'écraser d'un jeu cela enfin
sortir elle je me fais passer ne
retrouve pas avant de finir par flaubert
furan bernard et donc voilà on est resté
comme ça on s'est dit tiens un entretien
bref un des sketches on se marrait est
devenu un groupe ares est fun on crée
suricates ah ouais c'est rigolo que
nadal a créé un groupe de rock après un
accueil en effet un groupe de rock était
super nommé ans je vais tous de la bath
quarts de la
bastille et on n'est pas non plus
connaître ses voisines et bien ça fait
bien fait que des baskets
moyens on tape au débat sur ce peut-être
je passe tout de suite à la question de
thomas brunel qui demande êtes vous
comme dans friends un groupe d'amis qui
couchent ensemble mais on sait que c'est
vraiment des questions sérieuses je
pense qu'on est tous david schwimmer 7,9
lakic a couché avec qui dans le frais
sur la touche avec tous ces si les
[__] s'il allait même s'il a couché
avec rachel tu spoil oui car il ya vingt
jours
puisque cette offre le raid wedding de
coupe de france non mais non mais tu
l'as vu l'épisode uros il a failli
couché avec phoebe moi j'ai vu mais
peut-être que alors oui il ya des gens
qu'il ya des gens qui regardent bon
d'accord mais bienveillant et comme quoi
dans ce raid en effet ils ont ils ont
tous presque monica il ya un épisode
vous explique avant avant que rachel
débarque comment ils ont tous presque
fait coucher ensemble aussi les villes
et des champs fleuris
l'attendait bison burgat c'est pas
ça répond à la question valentin en fait
on va parler pendant une heure c'était
une grosse surprise
n'est déjà plus de 4000 weiwei 4000
personnes ça nous soit vous et coiffer
une part les tripes sion de malades on
va passer une question plus sérieuse
renie ses maths alors son prénom c'est
matt hashtag le mât aile marc l m ar qui
demandent est ce que vous allez faire un
movie versus live 3 et surtout pourquoi
une suite à mon vieux version live
plutôt qu'un autre sketch pourquoi une
si moi j'ai la réponse de mobilisation
gf3 si on ferme ou lisa soucha ex 3 ça
fait movies et c'est un film d'une heure
et demie et a juste avant le générique
mais life
pour moi ce serait la meilleure façon de
faire un beau visage fait froid ce 6ème
réunion
parce que vous êtes en train de dire que
vous allez faire un film
oui mais
voilà à faire un gif animé tout cas j'ai
dû revenir sur mon viseur soulève deux
justement si on l'a fait c'est parce que
ce qu'on avait c'est parce qu'on
continue n'avait vraiment envie d'aller
au bout du truc et de et de tout péter
en fait le dans on n'est pas en veine on
voulait pas voulait pas faire l'agglo
page agréable et surtout way et après on
s'est dit bon n'ont pas réussi sa
passion fait
récemment au caire si on veut tout péter
et parce qu'il me restait des vannes du
1 qu'on n'avait pas mis ce serait pas
mal dormi toujours pas mis
lamain ouais mais on n'en met mais pour
faire 1 3 il faudrait du coup reçu
reprendre sur 1 2 c'était un peu grave
toute notre créativité est par exemple
plus le truc c'est qu'on a mis enfin on
a un peu justement explosé du coup le
concept en est allé plus loin du coup
avec le 2 et du coup ça ce qu'on
pourrait par partir de cette base là
quoi donc c'est un peu compliqué il
faudrait faire vraiment autre chose
c'est faisable mais en même temps on
disait ça après le 1 qu'on ferait jamais
de 2 au lieu d'être enfin trois ans mais
ses programmes et persistant sketches et
justement je pense de tennis rijkaard
est faite directement 1 4 litre
j'avais fait un prequel comme moyen de 0
les gens genesis de man versus l'âge du
coup j'enchaîne avec la question
d'ophelia rose qui demande
par le pilou pilou ophelia qui demande
vos deux dernières vidéos sont plus en
plus barré cherchez vous à vous
démarquer encore plus ou à séduire un
nouveau public rochère faire virer on
avait cherché à séduire un nouveau
public de gens qui consomment de la
drogue voilà ça
je disais que genre les gens qui
regardent son compte parce que pour moi
justement ça veut dire ça m'énerve quand
on dit temple le cosmos à qu'est-ce que
vous prenez pour écrire ça ça m'énerve
parce que justement on est des gens qui
prennent rien et du coup en fait je
pense qu'il faut un esprit très sobre
pour écrire sur le truc
que tu peux québécois et du coup du coup
pour moi ces gens là ils sont dix
m'attriste parce que c'est eux qui
considère qu'il faut prendre de la
drogue pour eux car ça rappelle qu'en
soit il ya du travail c'est vrai que ça
rappelle quand même cerveau sous j'ai
dire que dès que des marques mais du
coup si je dis une marque de médicaments
faut dire les autres xanax
en tout cas pour revenir du coup à la
question on cherche pas à se démarquer
c'est tout ce que nous on cherche à
surprendre mutuellement un cheval a en
fait ça et du coup forcément on cherche
à se démarquer de ce qu'on a fait avant
pas forcément opposé mais ça c'est ce
qu'on aurait vu dans un sketch mais
qu'est ce qu'on aurait fait un mec qui
aurait voulu nous surprendre y aura du
ca aux arts et au bout d'un moment fait
ton travail tu es mon truc mais cela
n'entache s'arrêtera quoi en fait c'est
que quand tu es tout seul tu fais bon je
faire un nouveau voilà ça c'est fait
tiens je vais en faire un nouveau battu
alors que quand on a trois qui fait
[__] faut que j'arrive avec un truc
pour les faire marrer et qui va les
surprendre et du coup on essaie de
pousser le truc quoi tuer et justement
beaucoup de monde est-ce que vous avez
des projets solo parce que là tu parles
de projet justement à 3 ou s'il vous
surprendre chacun ce que vous avez
chacun des projets solos généralisée du
nouveau projet solo c'est déjà du
suricates viallard a su fédérer vie et
me dit bah je peux suricates avec toi
c'est vrai ça c'est sur gaza fait partie
de nos projets solo on continue
forcément la cote est d'avoir des trucs
je sais pas vous à des projets précis
par exemple julien
des vidéos à une chaîne youtube du le
fou est ce que vous vous avez des envies
de faire des vidéos n'ont vraiment pas
génial
tout bio sur sa chaîne qui sont quand
même assez exceptionnel 102 écriture
sans deux pattes
ben en fait je condamne au projet qui
était déjà avant sur icade qui continue
surtout quoi cet attrait pour le dit
dans le futur moi pour ma chaîne du coup
que shay toi et franchement qui continue
toujours frileux 10 jean charest qui a
fait un gros hit ces derniers temps que
l un des meilleurs des meilleurs france
56 secondes socrates est et puis voilà
donc c'est principalement la structure
impression parallèle c'est les trucs
qu'on avait déjà avant et qui continue
j'aime pas trop l'image que ça va donner
je suis en plus d'un petit village que
j'excelle on dirait qu'elle est fausse
et qu'elle
sait pas faire c'est sympa je veux juste
pour rappeler c'était la chanson qui
s'appelle henry le sait ça le titille il
avait dernière vidéo france
regarde sa poursuite magnéto magnéto on
s'attend à ce
que j'ai eu il ya des tanguy stradivari
qui pose une petite élite homme qui pose
une question pour julien est ce que tu
vis bien le fait d'être breton julien à
le mecque le mag et métis et saucier la
gueule des deux dvd origines de julien
salut dans glee
et ben oui voilà oui comme tous les
bretons je suis très chauvin je suis
content d'être breton jacques mais un
drapeau dans ma chambre et tout ce que
j'ai encore une chambre belge pas un
salon de thé j'ai pas un salon et une
chambre
suivant ses droits mais
le chemin c'est pas mauvais c'est juste
c'est comme si je disais oui à tous les
français c'est un peu chauvin je laisse
ça fait maintenant son chemin c'est pas
péjoratif il pas foncer le breton non
c'est pas péjoratif chauvin
a fait l'achat d'un autre côté on aidera
des bouquetins
tatatata temps ok
parler
non mais voilà et du coup oui j'en passe
moi j'en parle souvent dans la vidéo et
que revendique parce que j'aime bien et
que c'est beau la bretagne et en plus
même encore plus maintenant que j'y
habite mais ou de quel endroit et je
suis à côté j'aime bien qui pose la
question de savoir
est ce exact non mais c'est à côté de
saint malo ce bloc est donc au d'armor
tout ça ok voici les vilaines saint malo
mais oui tout de suite magnéto
et a connu il ya l'oncle sim qui demande
parmi tous
parmi toute votre vie parmi toutes vos
vidéos quels sont vos quel est votre
préféré
il n'a pas apprécié parmi toutes les
vidéos qui existent au monde où par les
nôtres alors permis de toutes vos vidéos
parmi les mesures il ya plus juste en
ces jeunes pose une question de
personnes c'est par marie messier mais
la vidéo préféré qu'on a qu'on a fait si
on a un attachement à l'avoir fait ou si
on avait pour moi c'est vrai qu'à la
leur a préféré le point là maintenant je
vais rien après un mec pour sa foi si tu
me dis elle a préféré avoir enfin c'est
le voyage soit joli jardin c'est
pourquoi moi c'est le contrat parce que
celle que vous êtes - tafer de surface
et sert de bouche-trou me suis plus un
spectateur non parce que là c'est
titanic
j'aimerais après petra j'ai très peu
bosser dessus des attentes à bosser un
taux de l'été selon l'inspecteur et puis
du coup je redis c'est vous mouche
football
et du coup j'en ai peut-être deux
c'était une dans ce cas j'en ai
peut-être 4
the desert storm the thing de raf parce
que c'est pas encore une sur icade c'est
raf qui débarque chez nous la crème
glacée des prémices et c'était la
première c'est qu'elle fonctionne en
plus mais je les ai vus et pareil en
spectateur et on était là on est dans
l'airé une hauteur quand on était une
quatorzaine du coup à chaque fois qu'il
repique chez son truc on se bidonner à
chaque fois qu'ils repêché le truc au
bout de la quatrième lecture y avait une
nouvelle vanne dedans on en poupe
franchement c'est pas ça revient figure
en dedans qui tombe sur un klaxon de
volée mais ouais il ya toi il ya s'est
gavé de
large et c'est là et est super heroes
hangover parce que pareil j'étais la
plus son spectateur j'ai écrit des
vannes mais c'est les deux mc qu'on ne
sait pas ce que tu as des prostituées
haut
débit et donc c'est vraiment l'art est
allé tout est gelé gct jean est la
dernière avant les prostituées dans la
rue tu sais ça libanais
voilà bien un petit ya evans qui demande
qui est le chef entre vous
pouvez dans les postes en fait pendant
des mois ouais ça nous avons eurostat
sur le compte twitter c'est un peu comme
c'était un chien qui avait apporté ça
c'était je pense que le manque de les
membres du cast de fraises allez on y
revient pour friends pour avoir une
unité dans l'eure dans leur décision
aussi grave avait voilà disait ça passe
tout passait par lisa kudrow quoique
avait dit ça a du coup tu nous l'a dit à
ses taux quand on a créé suricates on
s'est livré est un coup parfait
pour avoir enfin il faut il faut
déléguer il faut mais il faut mettre des
délégués de classe un peu tard par poste
et par machin et tout coup du coup genre
pour tout ce qui est un peu
rendez-vous administratifs etc julien va
dire vas synthétiser mes ventes en
italie terra mai
du coup c'est lui qui va plutôt être
notre porte parole et s'est plaint du
coût en fonction des postes on n'élit on
se fait déposséder
mais en gros ça ce petit à petit au
détachement qui petit à petit ressort de
même là encore on n'est pas encore il ya
des petits trucs qu'on fait ok là ça
commence à être mal rafting de sa
fratrie ou d'un kit mettons dont sont
ont goûté dans le sac et à celui qui va
se réveiller ce qui veut dire les mecs
les parents arrivent dans deux heures
absolument qu'on soit lavé on se partage
ça comme ça aurait été cool mais c'est
des petites habitudes j'avoue je sais
que vous n'aimez pas quand je parle de
coupe mais ça me plaît même chose mais
en gros quand tu construis un groupe il
ya des adultes qui se créent et apprend
à travailler ensemble et ça passe par
justement partie ok c'est tout celui qui
fait ça se situe fait ça quand on est
invité comme ça tu as et plus dansant
qui fait des blagues vincent blague
tu vois
mais en fait on débarque aux réunions
d'un soir on est crevé et tout en
faisant sans blague
mais non de l'émotion s'écrit pas très
cool en ciel - père de la blague l'ex
monsieur
et madame j'ai une dernière question
pour raf en torsion raf après tout
s'explique tu es sûr que tu la connais
en plus je vais néo néo qui demande
j'adore tes cheveux je me smiley qui
prend le mec mais pourquoi les coiffes
tu comme ça demande-t-il
en fait on
voudrait décembre en fait
et en plus ils ont pour tâche de fond et
en plus c'est que tu répondes très vite
parce qu'on va séduire chose c'était
chiant parce qu'on va bientôt accueillir
est évident donc soit tu réponds soit tu
pars mais pourquoi ses cheveux sont
bonnes les coeurs parce que j'aime
j'aime bien cette coupe j'ai mis 19 ans
l'a trouvée je suis content je veux mais
tu l'avais la naissance et son
implantation et son cuir chevelu l'état
on parle de cheveux de reddition vous
fait des vannes sur les ce et vous vous
mettez des tabourets trop bas
vraiment vous êtes des [__]
voilà
qu'au
niveau raf est attendu à ce qu'il a là
un sketch devait pas partir pour à
cannes on va partir dans les allées
merci à tous merci à raffaele vers
seraing tu fais avec 60 on s'est coincé
là bas c'est la taxe va obliger de
gallichan tellement tout le monde s'en
fout quand tu parles
dimanche pour toi par audi pour châu à
bientôt mec à quel moment où on s'ennuie
l'alcool à l'e3 j'ai pas compris qu'il
faut continuer on continue et qu'il ya
trois personnes qui nous regardent ça ça
vient d'ailleurs 5000 8000 voix on a
aimé le personnage parmi les bons jours
avant avant d'enchaîner en jeu mais la
cour un 2 2 un bug des concours et je
suis jetée région
nous reste quatre oui mais il se passe
des trucs particuliers ont fait le reste
j'ai plus de questions certains
spectacles c'est très bien alors bonjour
oui oui oui évidemment très bon jouer ma
vie je voyais alors je te présenter
rapidement tu me dises ici pas de
conneries donc davy mourier oui voilà
on a fait le tour des sujets on appelle
tournée s'est
étalée sur wikipédia
donc tu as fait le golden show avec
monsieur pop on a aussi connu dans des
reer et françois descraques et raphaël
décrite l'un d'eux
gérard dedans on confondait on a aussi
vu dans la web série de merde marie tu
présentes aussi road trip qui est une
émission sur la bande dessinée même
illustrateur de bandes dessinées wii est
assortie notamment dernièrement la
petite mort qui marche très bien par
mois oui ce que tu veux rajouter quelque
chose à 7 oui la petite mort marche très
bien
mais oui la bande dessinée tu veux la
trouver dans toutes les magasins
l'amazoo gras fnac virgin non pas parce
qu'ils sont morts
voilà chapitre non parce qu'ils sont
morts voilà mais chez games non ils sont
morts beaucoup de gens qui ferment
finalement c'est la crise oui non la bdl
et marche bien je suis très content et
je suis très fier d'être papa d'un
personnage qui a plus de gens qui le
connaissent que moi maintenant
il ya plus de gens qui ont acheté la bd
que des gens qui me suivent en fait
d'accord vidéo solo sur golden moustache
cette année c'était les podcasteurs
boulonnais et pokémon n'a vraiment pas
trop déçu lors de l'invasion
la première vidéo c'était pokémon
l'invasion fait ça c'est ça ou je parle
de racisme à base de pokémon parce que
j'aime les deux tu as menée
est ce que tu as d'autres vidéos je
suppose wii qui vont arriver si je
devais tourner aujourd'hui la
perche n'ont
alors pourquoi je sais pas j'ai pas
compris et je vais tourner de ce qui est
super drôle à
base de game of thrones qui est vraiment
bien ouais mais je sais pas si on va le
tourner et puis un autre ce qu'est ce
que j'ai déjà commencé à tourner mais on
n'a pas fini de tourner voilà
voilà d'accord à votre question ben
ouais j'en ai choisi insultant
j'ai des questions pour tout le monde
cette fois là qu'il y ait des paies à
double pénétration non
c'est à dire doublement des salaires
janssen faciale dit à jean luc azéri
granit mais
qui demande il ya andrew bignolles aussi
femme qui demande tellement c'est à ses
yeux ces grosses têtes une question dans
true bignolles
idamante ans quels sont vos meilleurs
souvenirs de tournage a tous quelqu'un
veut commencer peut-être mas des vignes
tu viens d'arriver non me faire
maquiller le cul oui
ça plus clair
c'est vieux mais sur un tournage de nerd
j'ai j'ai fait pipi dans mon costume
quand je suis allé aux toilettes en fait
j'ai pas fini de secouer ma bistouquette
et du coup la dernière goutte est tombé
sur mon costume équité en satin et en
fait ça fait des tâches de pipi comme ça
mais j'avais qu'un costume et du coup
heureusement j'étais j'étais assise du
coup en fait j'ai je suis revenu sur le
tournage en étant pliée et vu que
j'étais réa je suis arrivé comme ça que
je me suicide on canapé j'ai pris un
coup ça j'avais et on tourne j'ai espéré
j'ai raté mes scènes dernière ça a duré
assez longtemps et quand j'ai enlevé le
coup cinq ans et c'est fini c'est est
séché et donc personne n'a vu que je
m'étais uriné dessus
est ce que c'est la loose et vous à tous
les images
franchement j'ai vu dans la télé vous
n'avez pas vu encore mais on se dirait
vraiment sur nrj 12
ah les ventes à l'ailé je pense sont des
verts jusque là on en bouteille moi j'ai
bien soin esclave esca sur nrj 12 il ya
galettes de riz qui pose des questions
dont vous il
faut non seulement que tu peux vendre ce
que moi je l'aï ratée parce qu'à tanger
med gym à tata une chaîne ou pas bons
souvenirs aux tournois wpt est
aujourd'hui 90 parce que l'approché n'a
jamais oublié je viens de m'en souvenir
la première scène ma vie j'ai tourné
avec toi rares c'était je tâche de un
train de me branlette interne en
attendant les premiers rescapés 7 mai
mais quand c'est le premier jour à huit
heures du matin on a des sous un pont
des galas
de mes rencontres
sur golden chaud il y avait un truc
quand tu avais pas dit c'est que katsuni
arrêt te montrer ses seins oui c'est
vrai [__] je sentais que j'avais en
vigueur du dollar us
dans la post pop soul edge je sens
toujours mal sans m'avoir poupe débit
qui sont là je reviens pas alors que
georges devait être dirigée et il y
avait il y avait un plan ou luca toni
devait passer devant moi donc à tunis
mais qui était le personnage incarné par
davy à la base donc était censé être un
homme quant à l'intérieur et qui devait
montrer ses seins pour nous le sommes
parce que j'étais un collègue de davy
qu'il faisait chier et chanter qu'il y
avait anguille soirée puisque il y avait
personne sur le tournage c'est dans la
petite salle à ankama faire sa personne
avant et des caves et ce plan là tout le
monde à débarquer sortait leur iphone
discretos comme ça pour me filmer et
chantée qui avait un truc et du coup pas
forcément j'ai foiré la première prise
que je me suis marré parce que il avait
dit genre non elle va juste faire ça
elle fait ça pour de faux et tout et
puis oui j'avais 1
claude schopp des sainte catherines mais
mes parts par pudeur j'ai pas et part
pour l'actorat g foot et mes yeux
et j'ai regardé en rose le bâtiment
comme ça
sentait j'étais film est partout tu as
déjà jeté fille quelques jeux partout je
suis dit ah j'avais envie la deuxième
fois j'étais habitué j'ai pu vraiment
joué mais je me sentais un peu violée
dans le sens un peu genre les goonies
quand ils ont tourné les goonies ils
n'ont pas dit au petit j'arrive à y
avoir un bateau géant ils ont fait
débarquer dans l'endroit où il ya le
bateau géant à la fin et pour avoir des
vrais réaction club est vrai anecdotes
et pour avoir les vrais réaction des
petits qui font plus tard le décor géant
et du goodwill apporté un peu voilà ça
peut dire genre t'es un acteur de merde
on va te surprendre du agents
n'ont joué dans pire a déclaré karen une
version hard du tout quoi tu parles moi
non plus
je suis je le passais la question de
galettes de riz c'est
qu'elle est qu'elle est qu'elle était le
genre de vos premières vidéos et avec le
recul êtes vous satisfait de celle ci où
vous les trouvez plus drôle j'ai
peut-être commencer par vincent qui n'a
pas pu répondre à fait calme des lieux
sur internet depuis ces
questions là c'est une autre quelque
chose de sûr c'est que je commence quand
je parle j'aime bien ton anecdotes de
disait que les gens me disaient
peu à peu près
youtuber très gentil qui m'a dit c'était
pas mal et où je suis tombée sur ton
vieux blog et tout franchement points
hors de l'eau c'est un peu la honte et
tout mais franchement tous des grands
dossiers à tous des casseroles que j'ai
fait c'est mon blog actuelle en fait
donc peut-être pas lille et havanaise où
je m'en foutais parce que je l'assumé
mais c'est un truc
volontairement déglingue
certains diraient frappadingue des gains
de déglingos zinzins r d iran mais ce
n'est pas du tout mais c'est très
logique pour moi dessus il ya des
premières vidéos et du coup avec le
recul on sait pas mais première vidéo
j'en ai fait vraiment plein je les ai
jamais misé sur le net parce que étant
beaucoup plus vieux que tout le monde
j'attaque les 47 quand j'attaque les 47
lui donner les
noms mais l'état de la reprise ou pas
non bon alors guen
les voilà donc
voilà le topo quoi mes premières vidéos
ne sont pas sur le net à son sur un
disque dur chez mes parents non
franchement eu
les oueds on n'a pas tant que ça j'ai
une delorean qui voyage dans le temps et
d'un petit fx fait avec des bricoles des
bricoles folle comme un vieux renard est
plutôt que de manière générale le
séville battu les assume mais pour ce
qu'elles sont et le président est alors
que les gens tombent dessus ils disent
ah mais attends mais ça c'est carrément
rassemblé 11 10 genre il a fait ça rien
ne sert qu'à trop mou cerveau a muté
ouais ok c'est cool quoi mais est ce que
toi tu sais dans quel contexte de
youtube c'est que les gens des secousses
il découvre il découvre tout d'un coup
il a même des trucs dit à dix ans quel
référencement quand elle met tout de
suite dessus quoi tu as surtout sentir
et se retrouve en ton sur un dossier
dans itunes en sicile un film d'une
heure trente généralement le problème
c'est le montage voilà c'était conseils
des trucs trop l'on jouait mal ont ont
poussé des vannes comme des porcs et
tous il ya que ça que je regrette du
montage mais cette fois vraiment dire au
revoir à
rafah
et mais peut-être que peut-être que tu
répondras demain parce que demain on
peut vous retrouvez au max linder
panorama pour une soirée un poster ça
c'est juste pour prévenir ceux qui sont
peu au courant que en effet demain il ya
au max linder à paris grand boulevard à
19h30 20h par là il il ya une soirée
projection avec un best-of de tous les
sketches de la moustache mais surtout un
sketch inédit suricates qu'on a tourné à
montreux et qui est un petit peu spécial
d'ailleurs en couleurs j'espère qu'il va
vous plaire ce qu'est twitter facebook
chaîne youtube de montreux comedy
festival parce qu'on peut trouver aussi
plein de choses intéressantes mais on
nous invite pas puisque l'entrée est
payante
mais je crois que je veux faire alors je
veux faire gagner des places il faut se
renseigner sur tout le twitter golden
moustache tous car il ya encore des
places au revoir raf
voir et on va accueillir à la place de
rafael et crack adrien meyniel qui
risquent entre les appelants commenter
les
images uniques derrière leur écran ils
sont pareils ça va c'est pas du tout
neuf fois aujourd'hui c'est l'énergie
solaire bonjour salut a tous des
arméniens
bon adrien je vais présenter un petit
peu le stress
mais à part ça
ça va regarder s'il ya des caméras c'est
sûrement là
on est plus de 5000 un regard n'est
d'ailleurs ils sont que de simples et à
regarder parmi ces caméras ne convoite
pas le million c'est le but de la vie
des habitants c'est là pour très
longtemps alors adrien michaud adrien t
il eu ce tracteur entre autres ouais
j'ai été surtout bon tu arrêtes tu
gribouille un petit peu et où l'écouté
trucs sur la noire six buts avec moi
bakel comme c'est hélas non
tu as un peu explosé sur wein et était
incertain tapait le premier voire
meilleurs riders français tu veux
répondre à quelques jours consacré
d'ailleurs quelqu'un te dirai bravo pour
ton prix j'avais ces gens qui se passe
bien tous les rallyes s'inscrire stade
mais c'est pas une question bravo pour
ton prénom c'est
donc en plus d'être le meilleur weinert
est insupportable c'est si je suis
angoissé je m'attendais pas un truc
aussi propre en fait bizarre non mais on
a le droit de le salir un petit peu et
c'était dingue et ngog la golden
moustache tu veux parler un petit peu de
ton rôle à golden moustache alors
moi je suis
peut-être pas trop déconner tu m'as tu
es là déjà savoir granola
donc moi je suis arrivé comme auteur
auteurs quoi
juste je suis triste et on me demande de
vérifier ce ton micro est allumé sa
course s'est dit déçu alors je checke
moi je suis un peu et on ne marie pas
moi j'ai pas dit que jamais un spectacle
tous les vendredis à 21 ans c'était
prévu c'est d'accord ok
je répète un compte pendant que
converger en scène salut merci salut
merci voici je répète tout utile il faut
nous faire des jaloux maintenant qu'ils
ont convergé tu veux des vies on a mis
un paper board pour toi si tu auras
relais moi c'est mon de croquer quelques
trames énorme manque à gagner des pistes
mais c'est bon j'ai donné ma donnez moi
un peu comme je sais pas une impro un
truc tu normalement malaise lié à une
panne technique de micro tu peux
dessiner ça on vient de l'avoir c'est
pas la peine mélèzes
non mais j'ai gardé notre notre cas
dumas et marche pas merde alors pour
ceux qui regardent le club dorothée bas
pendant qu'ils dévient dessine son
malaise vagal on revient sur les
questions des internautes il ya monsieur
bananes flambées quand ils ont tous des
noms c'est totalement terminée je suis
j'ai fait des deux douches ou des
bêtises et auteur auteurs authors
hauteur et moustache il écrit
des d'evine comme des vidéos comme mais
comme des idées folles voilà les
turbulents des turbines mais peu créatif
je pense que c'était très bien voilà je
crois qu une personne aurait été mieux
du coup question pour vous tous monsieur
ban affirmait demande qu'est ce que ça
fait d'avoir un bis 1 million d'abonnés
nous rien
c'est si je sais pas si ça fait plaisir
c'est fallait faire c'est pas un million
pour pour rien se passer un million
groupé quoi donc c'est un travail assez
libre à tout moment que là tu vois je
dis rien c'est un corail collectif donc
la maison qu'on a tous un petit bout
d'chou un million et mais déjà c'est
vachement mon coach croit déjà
allés tous les deux en fait plein de
gens qui sont là pour nous dire je suis
abonnée
balance balance une idée je la
regarderai a volontiers et voilà il n'y
a aucun contrat de signer avec eux ils
sont là ils attendent une tape dans le
dos parfois il nous chamailler un peu de
nous chamailler
les gens sont
très calmes et c'est papa le soir elle
allait très vite amélie
adorons ça va très très vite j'imagine
que c'est beaucoup pour youtube par les
enrouleurs experts rappellent qu'ils
peuvent continuer de poser leurs
questions hashtag comme millions gm
voilà sur terre' le chiffre 1 billion
millions le gène m le mot en toutes
lettres et gm les initiales de grandes
grandes luttes comme des moustaches
il ya yvan horse ou orts je ne sais pas
comment on le dit qu'ils demandent quels
sont vos youtuber préféré
des
nazis le une tumeur que je ne préférais
que j'avais quand je connaissais rien
youtube et j'ai pu j'ai maté je veux
qu'il ya qui brûle en moi j'ai tout
regardé et je suis j'ai bloqué sûr que
marc et il m'a email recart et ses
danses dans ce sens dernière de cette
phrase
quand j'ai vu la vidéo au secours j'ai
pas trouvé le titre je suis au beau
alors mon style mon style merci le
rapport mais west ham évidemment je suis
un revenant je suis un gros bout tu leur
fais même pas de tête bah moi c'est que
m'a fait rire que ma terrasse trois mois
sachant que je ne regarde pas beaucoup
en fait ce n'est pas bien mais que marc
me fait beaucoup rire on joue tu me
regardes pas mal tu es tu devenu
aussitôt que même en effet me surprend
toujours ce qu'ils aiment bien que j'aie
jamais vraiment à quoi s'attendre
maintenant c'est vrai que je clique
balance une vidéo que j'adore je vais
devoir aussi parce que c'est un peu un
ovni dans l'univers de youtube française
faute arrive à le dire que vers la fin
de chou
tu vois rien
françois descraques aussi si on peut le
considérer comme youtube heures j'aime
beaucoup le visiteur du futur même si m
c'est un accès large du coup ouais j'ai
fini d'après la trachée narnia tomsk à
l'équipe il ya les ont pas conduit le
tueur avant lui m si on part du principe
que le mec est une bénédiction internet
et une caméra matin de cap
thomas sky fait de la bidouille encore
je crois il ya des vies qui aimerait
montrer son bassin oui alors
le malaise que tout le monde voit qu'il
a une croix gammée et que le micro
marche pas et qu'ils disent c'est juste
un déguisement chez pas raciste un
traitement c'est ben on va passer avec
bastien sur base d'un autre un autre un
autre
ami à moi qu'à soutenir al nîmes ça
alors c'est peut-être un peu nuageux ou
quelque chose de ninja quelque chose de
ninja
quelque chose je
le fais pas je le ferai pas je ne ferai
pas le ferai pas je le ferais pas
mais pas du tout alors questions suivent
il ya une question de marie avril i'm h
ayem qui te demande adrien meyniel je
voudrais savoir comment tu fais pour
être aussi beau tout le temps
alors ça il ya du trucage clairement
dans l'école semble allégations exemple
c'est une amie à moi c'est vrai
qu'ici
c'est une blague
alors je m'hydrate pas mal je prends la
vitamine b12 en supplément c'est déjà
trois motions voilà des petits gommage
des petits trucs comme ça
la bonne humeur et puis voilà quoi la
nationale est tout simple et la nature
lui ont exactement le mec roulent eux
petit truc c'est d'homme sa petite peau
et ça marche aussi si
je la retirerais
caméra sait pas qu'elle ait
quitté juste après on a vite c'est un
très très vite certes sur internet a
dégagé vers ses ennemis qu'ils demandent
est ce que enfin en fait pour vous tous
mais comme vous partez je vais vous la
posez en priorité est ce que vous pensez
faire autre chose que de l'humour sur
internet
si je dis je sais faire que ça ça veut
dire que je sais le faire donc en fait
c'est horrible c'est ma pause non ça je
suis très bon jardin c'est vrai mais je
suis très bon jardinier je m'occupe bien
je sais plante un rosier je sais taillés
dé mon pote et j'ai failli jardiner
j'essaie et au général s'il peut tuer
des gens sûrement dramatique
non mais brady n'a pas pas forcément de
l'humour
c'est le thème
c'est un dessinateur ninja ninja
du sexe mais on pourrait donner on
pourrait être au service d'autres choses
que de l'humour et c'est juste ce qui me
laissait à voir mais il est pour quelque
chose tu viens tu as trop le fond ce
rapide sur cette question ouais non mais
un peu pour moi en gros on fait déjà pas
que ça on met toujours que sita que
l'humour tout seul c'est pas marrant
donc il faut toujours un peu d'émotion
situe peut on dès fois ok on fait des
trucs débiles mais mais des fois c'est
quand même cool aussi quant à elle avait
fait un peu d'humour un peu d'émotion ou
alors un peu de drame et on essaye d
fois ponctuellement de faire et voilà
mais même du liban des trucs aussi con
que veut des vieilles stop au betting tu
greffe un peu de drame dedans tu vois du
drame sensationnel tu vois à
l'américaine c'est vrai mais c'est quand
même du g 20
concrètement la
voilà je suis obligé de vous dire on
s'en va football varsovie fais ce que tu
veux avec des bananes
intersidéral merci tu veux qu'à la
méduse c'est ton idée les ninjas je te
le donne au revoir vincent merci
beaucoup de questions et on va savoir
tout faire
un petit câlin
et on va recevoir yacine et dedo
ouais
c'est très bon
je chantais suis vraiment allé me adrien
miel pur et très beau ce que vous faites
vas-y un thème
j'aimerais des vacances le soleil
du désert bonjour là bonjour tu as
longtemps comment bien les vrais lits
affiner les eaux écoute ça va nous ça va
super bien ça va ça va très bien est ce
que je peux vous demander une petite
présentation rapide vous voulez vous
présenter
cette ya six mois je vois là bien
présente et tout le monde donc je suis
yacine et dedo way et je fais les
chaussettes mais c'est à dire que je
m'entends super bien avec l'om que je
m'amuse bien quand au fait des trucs et
du textile et au fait des décors aussi
voilà je
tombe à l'histoire à signer les nouveaux
recevoir tout de suite
du coup qu'est ce que c'est l'histoire
racontée par exemple tu seras jamais il
parle déjà qu'est ce que c'est
l'histoire contée pas je sais de faire
exister avant golden moustache extrêmes
en battant par bhp existe depuis 2007 on
a fait des pilotes et après nous on dit
c'est vachement bien venu on vous paye
on a dit avec plaisir et c'est ainsi que
sur
une roulette
cette seconde parce qu'on est payé pour
le si on parle de l'histoire et en fait
on revisite l'histoire absolument avec
des chaussettes when the station un peu
façon a fallu
une façon rigolote d'une façon
complètement décalé décalage beaucoup de
décalages arrive déjanté par des jantes
est un peu inattendu on est un peu plus
lui ben bernanke a perdu vers l'ouest et
d'ailleurs jules demande jeudi et déjà
prévu la fois qu'il ya donc une
transition un match nul pour faire
l'histoire racontée par des chaussettes
et vous utilisez des chaussettes droite
gauche ou les deux alors on a ça dépend
c'est en fonction des périodes les
années paires de l'avant turquie dont on
parle on utilise les chaussettes droite
et les années impaires que je possède
même genre de la révolution française
c'est gauche 1889 absolument et la
création des pyramides ses droits taxes
le quatre sans combat très rares les
chaussettes ne trouvent pas ils marchent
pas des deux côtés des piétons n'ont pas
la sec sont seulement on y tient
vraiment dire oui et ça se voit
la gauche doit bâtiment chez nous c'est
des chaussettes c'est des chaussettes
exprès de l'udc social pour la télé
s'est déchaussé comédienne en plus
absolument internationales sont payés
sont cachés raison des cachets voit
souvent cédé international et
internationale dont nous parle aussi
anglais we say me faisait beaucoup de
londres
et dans le désert ouais mais non ils
sont ma
voix c'est l'avion il ya toujours un
mini côté bloqué là
vous n'avez pas fait le rapprochement
parce que je m'en vais parce que je
reviendrai
allez hop génitales dans l'ostréiculture
ok les huîtres les 8 à coup sûr des
huîtres non c'est pas la poule 1 c'est
l'huître est assez con parce qu'avec les
moules mary chien auquel c'est un peu
chiant comme thème l'ostréiculture en
milieu tempéré
soit là c'est plus large et alors je
peux proposer le strict culture a emmené
et en paix et les gendarmettes ah oui
faire un rappel de funès et quel aveu et
c'est quand même ça qu'on ya juju 13 si
ça existe déjà mais s'appelle gck des
jurés n'avaient en fait votre regard
vous savez dieu des codes et non en
girouette judiciaire de 89 à temps juju
briac moi aussi j'ai twitter okende
camatte est détruit @ juju traîne si tu
veux savoir il ya juste eu trait ce
qu'ils demandent comment vous êtes vous
rencontrés yacine et dedo on a beaucoup
de versions
du marché et sera édité chez flammarion
jeu juste marcher je me souviens de
marché ouais marche marche résultat une
phlébite cetef les mythes il faut
marcher deux ans
jordan sur cette histoire alors ya la
première la première c'est en sortant
deux en sortant de prison c'est vrai
personne c'était la première la deuxième
c'est dans un dragon c'est çà et là 3e
23e c'était lors de l'explosion de la
traque dans un parc d'attractions moment
où il aurait soit disant sauver la vie
et c'est celle là qui est plus proche de
la vérité parce qu'on s'est rencontrés
dans une salle de réunion du comedy club
mais à walibi walibi j'en suis baba
oui mais je trouve donc oui je trouvais
que ça l'autre
avec toi et
que tu veux bien un truc
voilà
merci pour cette question les ans mais
je vois la question ils sont quadrillées
va pas être content alors que l'on va
rester longtemps en plus donc c'est
margaret landers qui demandait ce que ma
part claude envers sa soeur de marat
graceland à l'invention de la news des
noms aussi dans les micros combien j'ai
micro 7 ouais
non je suis sur rhône non non c'est
votre chum utah niveau technique sont un
peu de la merde ça veut dire tout ce que
j'ai dit on n'a pas entendu c'était
tellement drôle jean cholette on va
devoir tout refaire des dos a été
tellement long était incroyable et je
suis un parfait a par contre si vraiment
tous ceux qui savent lire sur les lèvres
ils ont qui fait ça je le sais chers
internautes vous les avez pas entendu
toutes les blacks et d'idéaux je suis
garant c'était à mourir de ne jamais
sortir aulas sortiront aussi dans un
bouquet à thé chez fleuve noir au sein
de la sélection un peu plus classe est
plus restreint comme publicis et du
seignal août merci des vivres hésiter un
autre formidable et j'ai offert arrêtez
de vous enfilez aux messieurs d'un génie
mais
et les gendarmettes c'est exactement ça
ah oui pas d'accord parce que tu en
avril et perles des gens morts
alors
que c'est mieux cognac jay est ce que
vous m'entendez génial bien c'est bien
d'avoir attendu dix minutes en plus
j'aime ça mais on est au faîte du
entendant sa voix chaude et du coup je
reviens sur le cinéma j'ai même pas dj
pas posé la question en fait il ya sinon
on a pu le voir déjà au cinéma
absolument et c'est de là que margaret
découvre sa question est-ce que vous
avez des projets en cinéma commun ou
autres ou alors cela non mille 1000
projets allaient là moi je vais aller
voir captain america la semaine
prochaine marche parce que ça fait un
bail que toi là ça c'est vrai américain
de l'oeuvre s'est passé mais qu aux
soldes d'hiver
bravo on a plein de projets mais bon
comme vous pouvez le voir on ne peut pas
encore en parler parce que c'est ces
patients pas sûr de pouvoir c'est pas
sûr encore on ad on a des projets on a
des idées on a des envies on a des
pitchs on a déménagé vraie pizza cinéma
les briochins on a des pizzas on a
vraiment des idées des bribes de
scénarii oui et
j'ai reçu j'ai 15 ans parce que ce
plateau mais très facile et ça ça va
passer du conseil ça c'est un petit
déjeuner d'hélène et les garçons et on
est dedans pour répondre à ma garde pour
ne pas le mot crespel faits qui nous
envient on a plein plein plein d'idées
mais on n'a pas encore on aimerait avoir
10 millions d'euros donc s'il y avait
bien nous les donner pour faire ce film
on est partant pour la deuxième question
une vraie à eux ouais une vraie ça super
mais non mais parce
qu'ils les connaissent pas moi je les
connais
quelques connards de noël à votre bd
elle en est où si vous deviez une bd
dont on réfléchit on réfléchit un
scénario de bd ouais il s'en est
contenté d'annoncer sa mort fin août ont
cependant bien c'est vrai bref c'est
trop mais toi parce que tu as bien
raison n'a plus un doute projets en même
temps mais c'est vrai ma bd c'est un
truc qui de chauffer on a peut-être le
cast d'en faire une et si un jour on off
et une aile sera édité chez castorama
merci dhabi pour cette question qu'est
ce que ça veut dire que tu nous aimes
bien et nous on est touché jean d'avila
une dernière une dernière question pour
toi et après
est-ce que c'est manu tremblant qui
demande aux renault un jour la joie de
revoir ou de voir un nouveau golden
chaud non le golden shoe c'est fini a
priori
genre mais vraiment le golden chose
c'est fini a arrêté de me poser des
questions voilà monsieur poulpe fait son
chemin avec studio bagel et canal+ je
n'ai pas choisi cette fois
cette déclaration
voilà vous rendez vous donné vendredi à
20h la nouvelle scène à côté de notre
dame de paris c'est une salle de
spectacle sur l'eau donc ne mangeait pas
avant de venir me voir j'ai déjà eu des
cas de vomissement pour deux oui les
gens volistes moi mon père il avait le
mal de mer heroes tales pendant tout le
spectacle j'entendais mon père
donc éviter de boire ou de manger avant
le spectacle
c'est à 20h tous les vendredis jusqu'à
fin juin voilà merci beaucoup
au revoir merci bien qu'il continue à
faire nrj 12 c'est la joie et bâle honte
à moi j'ai une question pour toi comment
tu te sens dans ce rôle de présentation
puisque je crois que c'est une grande
première pour quoique présenter cette
émission surtout moi j'ai une deuxième
question est ce que c'est
une question qui est complémentaire à
celle ci pour toi c'est
se donner un haka bis 2 présente à temps
mais parce que j'ai rien comme babylon
au dos mais je dis pas qu'elle est nul
je dois dire quoi la baisse est ce que
c'est fait pour être est ce que ça cadre
un pressage il a le même statut
je pense qu'il a un beau look absolument
il a voulu donner cette formidable
impression de leader meneur de jeu du
débat comme j'ai l'impression qu'on se
fout vraiment de ma gueule à nous
accueillir n'avons
on a beau
chanter un
jour
c'est un peu une matinée ressortez mais
sa matinale pas ça c'est vrai les
bananes les patates un
café aussi je sais à quoi faire le dos à
dos je joue à [__] ce que je fais le
dos à dos appel à moi je fais la vieille
tu fais l'invité là je regarde je suis
prêt quand tu veux pour un dos à dos à
dos à dos c'est quelque chose
à table et trois
quotas puis ça fait d'être asian
bastard mais bon chaque parce que 14 kg
c'est vrai en plus ça qui est fou ce qui
les fait en balsa ça tombe bien parce
qu'on avait une question d'honneur quel
est ton poids d'origine et pendant je
vais alors adrien va pas être content
parce que je vais parler nous n'avons
été hyper content des cela n'est pas
content parce que je sais pas pourquoi
maintenant je suis content
parce que tout à l'heure et c'est un
soutien pour me faire insulter
reste tarascon temps j'espère que je
suis pas content à la télévision en
termes absolument que depuis tout à
l'heure on pose des questions à tout le
monde sauf à adrien qui peut-être
s'appelle nrj group mais ben écoute il
s'est plaint de question qu'on fait en
plus honte à demander pourquoi tu es
aussi beau alors mais voilà moi je veux
une femme like your logo
le jura depuis depuis tout à l'heure je
me dis ça donc donne moi ton niveau est
ce que tu veux te présenter ou est ce
que tu veux que je te présente c'est
triste à dire beaucoup de bêtises donc
n'avons on ne connaît pour bref
autres connaît pour bref tu étais le
deuxième de brefs avec kyan khojandi
non
moteurs n'a pas dit l'autre il a dit le
gardien bah ouais donc tu étais l'auteur
qu'enfin coauteur coréalisateur là
vraiment je stresse pour pas dire de
bêtises parce que je sens qu'il est au
taquet mais on est on est au top là
c'est vrai et on ne connait aussi pour
la bande pas dessinée qui était à la
base un blog ces charmantes de dire
qu'on me connaît avec comme tel mais si
on connaît tout le monde se connaît et
on va encore mieux de connaître parce
que j'aimerais savoir bien là des radios
des intestins voilà quelques restaurants
quel a été ton rôle sur et vous quel est
ton rôle sur golden moustache en fait
j'ai été directeur artistique
à la rentrée dernière golden moustache
voilà c'est quoi dire que je supervise à
des sketchs
qu'elle vit que des petits jeunes
alors je sais plus il ya les chaussettes
absolument la bonne chance à elle sur
scène bras et d'ailleurs ça va continuer
c'est elle que son travail va continuer
à être vus parce que les prochaines vous
sortir bientôt on a travaillé ce attend
avec une impatience
le 21 ans revil il me semble que nous
avons le prochain on dit pas de quel est
le thème mais c'est sympa voici
maintenant une petite exclu perso
ce mode très ardue le sait sur le cheval
de troie est donc ces voix là c'est très
sympathique vous allez voir je dis
sympathique jeu pas pourquoi mais parce
que je n'avais pas dogmatique trois
syllabes ça fonctionne donc on a il a
été directeur artistique sur ces
épisodes la merci à lui prévenir naveau
sait quels sont les critères pour
sélectionner une vidéo que quelques
commandes là-bas car
c'est lui qui est plus avant dans une
paroisse qui peut frapper fort être mais
en même temps c'est lui qui gagne si la
loi du plus fort et du plus drôle c'est
pas le tout d'être fort faute soit ne
doit rien faire du mal il faut aussi
connaître la punchline fossoy rigolo au
moment où le mec contre elle une vraie
gorman des prises non quoi dire faut que
ce soit marrant ouais et percutant et se
trouve changée peut-on bien structurée
pour être ennuyeux en véritable machine
soit jusqu'à d'injustice une réponse
sérieuse enfin une réponse vrai je
dirais qu'il faut que ce soit au plus
proche de la personne qu'il écrit c'est
très beau et très vrai parce qu'il faut
pas faire ce que tu crois que les autres
attendent de toi il faut faire ce que
toi tu as envie de faire en espérant que
les autres attendent ça j'ai pas compris
mais tout ce que tu avais dit avant
c'était très beau et très vrai
l'argent surtout non en fait c'est parce
que quand on m'a proposé
on m'a dit qu'ils avaient yacine et dedo
adria
que je pouvais aussi amené des gens dont
j'étais très content d'amener la lucien
gromanova du québec antoine fiévet plein
de joueurs pas tout c'est à dire je te
connaissais pas donc c'est pas contre
toi mais en fait ça fait plein plein
plein de gens que j'aime bien et j'étais
super content de bosser avec eux voilà
c'est la vo mais je les trouve
je vais vous poser une question pour
dans l'internaute qui s'appelle the
goutte qui devant la slovaquie 7 c'est
vrai petit
messi a pas trois mais bien la posture
mais sa maîtresse a fait des hommes ça
fait des scolioses après faire subir ce
qu'ils demandent pas j'attends que
clémente pendant combien de temps vous
pensez continuer à faire des vidéos 14
mois alors qu'elle passait mois 7
6 14
mois jusqu'à fin 2012
après j'arrête
on continue ou non la mort possible
jusque là moto2 plus d'essence mec
jusque-là moto est plus essentielle
c'est beau c'est beau tout est bon dans
mes filles métaphore filée à bazas de
garage tant que ça nous amuse
de
l'année prochaine vous êtes vous êtes
ailleurs à une loge
tout nalbou la part du lion moi j'ai une
question pour toi adrien donc c'est
juste que ça t'amuse camp jusqu'à ce que
ça a de t'amuser c'est vraiment le monde
entier imagine dans cinquante antennes
star incroyable par tout ça tu as fait
tu fais des milliards de gens dans le
monde entier dit voilà cas c'est pas mal
ça arrête de nous amuser et que toi que
ça amuse tu continues
à jean yanne à 9 milliards d'aujourd'hui
il faut des assauts en attendant il ya
des associations tout le monde dit que
c'est pas marrant je cartes incluant sa
cible mais tu peux le faire mais ça l'a
été chez toi tout seul à la caméra tu
peux faire est qu après + où es tu sais
que les gens et ça c'est pas mal mais
toi
rachat d'or c'est bien c'était jusque
boutiste et c'est ça qu'on est bon je
sais pas mais vous on aurait eu ni sur
son nez je résidais
s'arrête mais bon voilà les
trois mois
une dernière question pour fuck you
sauce
collégiale cette dernière question pour
yacine et dedo mais vous pouvez tous y
répondre à ces deux dents drac sidr ou
drax haider qui donne avant d'être
produits par une chaîne tv comment vous
faisiez pour financer vos projets trop
de moi je sais pas moi j'ai ce que j'ai
de la chance de fait d'avoir des
cuticules pousse très vite on vendait
way band aid ça c'est très des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques beaucoup
pour les trucs des animaux d'accord ça
l'histoire connaissez quand il fait des
trucs pas financé ouais c'est vrai pièce
de théâtre wen a trouvé énormément bin
ouais si ça
représente les premiers premier épisode
on les a autofinancé wales est financier
tout seul et est en fait n'a pas besoin
d'être financés en fait pour être
marrant en démarrant tu peux faire des
petites choses rigolotes chez toi pour
moment normalement
ah bah oui parce qu'ils payent déjà nés
en fait parce qu'ils allaient déjà plus
le troc en plus ça permet d'échanger
tout ce qui est ce qu'ils aiment des
marchandises voilà les échanger contre
de la monnaie c'est du coup ça nous
permet derrière de pouvoir s'alimenter
mois faible acheter des vêtements de
louer des raisons de prendre voyage
acheté des gants
se brosser les dents
du mascara pour les cils de tout ça moi
j'attendais que tu finisses talent et
nous l'exhaustif l'a vraiment là mais
pour clôturer oui il est possible de ne
pas être financés et d'être quand même
suffisamment intéressante pour plaire à
des professionnels parce que les finales
ils sont là ils savent quoi faire je te
dirai qui n'ont prouvé devant leur
caméra elles ont réussi à faire des
trucs tout à fond merci beaucoup il a
signé des deux vous avez loupé ce que
vous faites sur scène parce que vous
venez d ouais fait de la scène oui voilà
une droite vas-y pas le premier aime moi
je je fais
moins violent n'était pas sur
le droit est bien là ça va être surtout
les chaussettes pour moi ça va être le
travail des chaussettes j'écris aussi
des trucs pour golden moustache pour
bientôt on verra bien voilà je suis pas
sur scène encore en ce moment d'accord
je travaille dans des petites scènes
mais je joue en anglais je joue en
anglais je préfère absolument je prépare
un festival d'edimbourg au mois d'août
donc pour ceux qui veulent savoir
comment ça se passait bien facebook tout
ça donc voilà des signes bellouz
facebook twitter très bien des dos d'âne
moi je serai toujours on va continuer
jusqu'à ce que souffle puisse se faire
voilà
sinon après pour la scène moi j'ai mon
spectacle en tournée là je joue samedi à
marseille par exemple un poste à galène
samedi venait il reste encore des places
je prépare la captation du spectacle en
jouant qui sera à paris mais j'ai pas
encore la date quand j'aurai la date là
l'ami murray dans le ciel formidable je
pense que c'est le meilleur moyen de
faire de la com jeu bah j'espère bien
parce que c'est la moindre des choses je
bosse sur le deuxième spectacle
actuellement et je suis aussi j'aurais à
tourner et non pas encore pour l'instant
c'est jeter soumettrait une liste eh
bien j'espère bien choisir l numéro 4
avec plaisir et je suis aussi doublure
derna dette sur leur tournée dont je
participerai au spectacle derna dette
sur certaines dates
avignon et puis aussi à le 19 avril à la
halle 6 à nice ah ça je savais pas ça
par alès le deuxième tour on peut pas
tout de suite mais donc la tournée le
stand up et principalement l'actu chaude
c'est samedi à marseille et la captation
du spectacle en jouant à paris venaient
en masse très bien mon spectacle pour la
capitale spectacle je viendrai me fait
plaisir tu viens alors 14 juin avec
plaisir moi franchement il ya un cas qui
vient aussi flaubert je l'espère
puisqu'il n'a pas s'ils lèvent la main
quand même cool news cela dit me relève
pas la main merci beaucoup et les autres
ça si ça y est ça lève la main
collégialement goeman un faux cul est
sympa et super plaisir merci beaucoup
yacine et dedo d'être venu sur nrj12 et
bas est en fait plaisir les bravos pour
tellement vrai c'était
génération reçoit tout de suite on peut
interroger ce qu'on peut revenir avec un
bris maigri mais différemment revient
changé de place oui s'assurer que toi
c'est vrai tu vas pouvoir m'aider parce
que là je suis débordée j'aimerais voir
et bravo bravo d'arizona oui
c'est vrai gros magot ça va
hinault et antoine chomsky qui va
arriver
si la foule one jose qui
incarne la petite iq routes
alors non comment ça va greg c'est bien
tu veux te présenter à nos amis
internautes à taper crainte non je
marque et greg
je regarde là alors je l'appelle greg
romano je suis à la base humoriste j'ai
un spectacle sur scène j'ai intégré
l'équipe de golden moustache là à partir
du mois de septembre grâce à un nabot en
fait qui m'a gentiment proposé de
commencer à écrire de devoir de tester
ça s'est plutôt bien passé donc voilà je
fais partie de l'équipe de golden depuis
septembre d'accord très bien et non
comme antoine ce qui là j'ouvre la
chaume
une petite présentation ce qui peut-être
il faut jouer présentement ça et bien
entre elles chomsky comédien et auteur
entre autres pour gold moustache
que je rajoute quelque chose
la fed un peu la scène effectivement
gérard one man show au point virgule et
dimanche et lundi à 20 heures c'est un
spectacle d'humour sur l'univers
carcéral qui s'appelle et les spectacles
légers qui s'appelle qui s'appelle au
parloir chomsky au parloir très bien
c'est noté je sais pas du tout à fait
rien noté première question pour vous
tous c'est
difficile qui demande comment faites
vous pour trouver toutes les idées avez
vous une source d'inspiration à
particulier les vols la plupart du temps
la vie c'est la vie vous avez tous les
jours
voilà fut bien vous pouvez répondre un
bain adrien du cookie
oui voilà qui fait de mal à non mais
c'est toujours un peu bizarre de
répondre à ce genre d'action parce que
ça peut venir de n'importe quoi donc
vraiment quand on répond la vie à
michael fincke ont
donc rémi gaillard t milliards quoi
ao d'accord
voilà
tu vois tu parles tu te fait interrompre
dans une phrase attend ça m'énerve quand
on interrompt elle n'a pas tout dit elle
serait marrant si de faire un sketch où
le mec et il fait interrompre tout le
temps et après c'est que ça veut dire un
bug de tout comme sa petite faim c'est
bon ça peut partir et il se fait
interrompre plusieurs fois jean
reno ça peut être un bon sketch
bonvoisin prévient surtout si c'est avec
des primes
s'est dégradé et toi navotas une source
d'inspiration en particulier quand moi
en fait c'est juste je pense qu une muse
s'est posé sur mon épaule ont fait est
que voilà me souffle à l'oreille des les
meilleures blagues de ma génération à
des projets en cours de tai écrit encore
du coup pour oui j'écris pour greg
romano fois son spectacle en laque rouge
était pas une crampe ce parce qu'il
respecte voilà c'est pas pareil c'est
parce qu'il m'impressionne il n'avait
peur que le frappe il a vu là c'était un
geste amical j'écris pour ken
qu'aujourd'hui son spectacle aussi sur
l'espagne qui est donc je vous croyais
de règles de break on a les pieds
l'autre ex devrait nommer ses grandes
connaissances
pour shirley souagnon qu'une petite
noire lesbiennes et pour sebastian marx
qu'un américain parie que mary lester
qui ne peut rester très bien greg
antoine vos sources d'inspiration pour
les sketches où la scène balade en
l'occurrence et moi ma mère
essentiellement thomas normand en fait
on avait souvent beaucoup d'idées mais
quand déjà tu commences à sélectionner
les trucs sont pas faisable les a trop
cher les trucs youtube tant que tu
penses qu'ils sont drôles et après quand
tu les écritures vite tu penses que
c'est de la merde au début tu peux avoir
une vingtaine d'idées après il en reste
une qui est viable et où après c'est oui
c'est des scènes de la vie quotidienne
c'est des trucs qui te font rigoler à
toi après tu sais pas aussi si ça m'a
fait rigoler les autres personnes qui
vont regarder donc c'est toujours assez
aléatoire après les idées c'est bien
n'importe quand je ne suis pas en train
de conduire en voiture tu vois un truc
ce serait marrant sont les inscriptions
ça moi je préfère moi je les vois tu
veux manger quelque chose aussi de la
mer de grecs c'est pour ça que sur la
pornographie et le suicide mais après ça
va un peu partout où je vais pas bloqué
comment oui ça se terminerait pas de
problème tout cela
il ya un bulbe bul bat pèse qui
demandent qu'en faites-vous des vidéos
très large pour le coup c'est à dire
david est aux commandes et vidéo sur
internet les vidéos
se prend la parole c'est très récent moi
je suis un nouveau
golden c'est d'aimer première vidéo on
va dire j'ai fait des vidéos qui était
lié à un peu aussi à mon spectacle et
que je continue de faire mais c'est très
récent pour moi je cette aventure là et
ça me plaît bien
depuis
septembre je fais des vidéos est que de
nos âges depuis septembre je crois que
c'est en septembre que a sorti la
première le dr la première est de batman
conso superman pas la première que j'ai
écrites ou la première qu'est sorti et
voilà et puis depuis ben j'en ai sorti
deux autres je crois et la troisième qui
sort jeudi enfin demain normalement
mais vu le retard vu qu'on est là en
train de faire le mariole et qu'on peut
pas bosser donc voilà donc normalement
on essaye de me
compliquer
voilà moi paris quand wayne je
commençais à septembre
des vidéos avant mais qui marcherait
jamais ma plus belle vidéo sur youtube
elle a dû faire 23 vue mais maintenant
qu'il ya culture non mais papa dans le
cadre des moustaches maintenant jusqu'à
voir les golden moustache ça permet
d'avoir un cadre professionnel avoir une
vraie équipe technique et avoir des
vidéos qui sont bien faites c'est sûr
après ça aide aussi à ce qui est le plus
de vues mais sinon oui mes premières
vraiment vidéo professionnelle c'est
depuis le mois de septembre l'activité
professionnelle fait des vidéos amateurs
aussi avec la mère de navo mais ça ça
rien à voir si ça avait été mis sur
youtube
je faisais de vous dire qu'il ya un
portable qui fait un peu de bruit est ce
que c'est un tic tac ça fait alors parce
que si c'est un futur
d'or sont les choses que cette question
soit choisi ben voilà à l'heure actuelle
pour cent pour cent 100 % on est tous
d'accord signé bio très bien alexandre
boulnois qui demande par de petits
problèmes le truc avec saint benoît qui
demandent 'est-ce que golden moustache
envisage des featurings avec des
artistes comiques dans le silo norman
cyprien ou autres ce que vous avez une
réponse à ça est ce que vous envisagez
un featuring avec d'autres artistes
comiques d'internet ou pas moi je suis
contre mais je suis pas la preuve
contre carrément
au contraire j'espère que c'est prévu
c'est l'internet c'est fait pour se
mélanger ils sont jeunes beaux
libidineux mais que toi qu'ils entendent
où on n'était pas très bien dormi
longtemps c'est pour ça que suis arrivé
chez golden si on peut appeler pour
amener ses soeurs est de 12 un peu
magicien
comme un raciste on m'a dit qu'ils les
avaient pas trop des acteurs qui
composent donc un antisémite en plus
rien ça me gênait de dire là que je sais
qu'en live qu'on peut pas le couper mais
c'est vrai quelqu'un faut répondre à
cette question est
ce que vous avez réalisé vie turing avec
d'autres artistes du net ou pas sur les
cours du caoutchouc
a créé une vidéo pour les faire on écrit
les vidéos du bastia on verrait bien lui
dans huit dents alors ils trouvent ça
peut être normal ils trouvent ça peut
être francis huster jean sérien tu vois
donc c'est pas on fait pas des vidéos
pour vous et pour les mettre de grosses
exclues
peut-être que voilà une vidéo qui va
sortir il francis huster mais chardy
papus
naveau ce que toi de ta vision
extérieure de directeur artistique tout
a été dit pour mais je pense que tout
allait peut-être mieux tout est dit
comme la pomme d'eddy mitchell très bien
et bien sûr cette phrase que tu vas nous
quitte et adrien
dernier mot quelque quelque chose dont
je suis bien où je vais juste le prendre
des gâteaux même à dix prochaines années
pour rien ça je prends
ces potentats opposants
merci beaucoup en tout cas rien non mais
c'était c'était très chouette ces titres
est vraiment une bonne ambiance
moi ce que j'étais content de partager
cette table avec toi
merci beaucoup adrien on va recevoir
tout de suite hakim hakim onirique en
lui
même bonjour hakim salhi garde ça
j'aime beaucoup ta vanne
ces trucs avec un salad il vous l'a
souvent fait quand je suis trop content
non mais en fait sur mon facebook
j'avais dit pour les places pour max
linder je les tire est en live pour ceux
qui répondait à mes questions tu algérie
avec un mois le 8 août vélo c'est pas
possible ça et du coup bah si vous me
tirer il ya juste deux papiers attirent
et tuent mais 1-1 ce que je sais que tu
motif et vas-y gelé tout de suite je
t'aime pas vas-y sauriez vous sortez les
noms alors c'est en lique 1 ouais une
écriture de meuf alors c'est sa mairesse
pestana et c'est quoi non mais c'est un
pseudo de ou mal ou privés voilà ça
myspace est en deuil malou prélever du
livre à reading and a gagné genre
colette a changé mais qu'elle serait
d'accord tu pourrais lui dire ce qu'elle
a gagné sa place pour le voilà l'un des
repas les deux ont gagné deux places sur
la soirée spéciale zes actuelle des
moustaches alors hakim ça m'a bien tu es
content d'être là sains banon mais je
suis forcée mais c'est vrai on n'est pas
comme ça est-ce que tu as tu veux te
présenter aux internautes qui nous
regardent ouais ce qui doit se demander
qui s'est en fait donc je suis de paris
fait partie de la nouvelle équipe avec
antoine ce mec là et d'autres et j'ai
déjà sorti deux vidéos qui sont l'arabe
du coin et anti spoiler et une pub pour
sfr aussi qu'on avait fait et
voilà je fais du stand-up principalement
principal c'est bien un président qui
s'appelle hakim est super gentil way qui
joue au pouvoir tu continue de le faire
vous tous les samedis 20 heures au
panama 13les près de république à paris
moi je suis pas allé et j'ai adoré
ça devrait ne pas venir je crois que tu
va nous quitter sur cette phrase
d'un spectacle c'est à dire que moi je
pars et flaubert bien non c'est lucile
va pas chez moi j'ai pas faut faire
c'est lucien qui vient et flaubert est
juste à côté si tu veux le voir ouais
mais faudrait de parler devant les
caméras je me dis offrant un petit truc
qu'on s'oriente donne je lui demandé
merci beaucoup d'amour d'être venu
qu'avant d'avoir par le temps qu'il fait
paraître cocasse
donc lucien peut revenir parmi nous si
ça tu présentes aujourd'hui elle ne
ferait pas tout fait très bien par
exemple les projets alléchants le 27
août à l'union je sais que tu as
maintenant je m'en vais sourire j'ai que
ça depuis
meurs
j'ai prouvé la faire aucun faux maquis à
moi même à mon derrière compass bonjour
le chien ça va les chiens je les entends
tu vas bien va super tu es content
d'être là ouais bah il ya une super
ambiance ouais parce que en coulisses il
ya plus de gâteau depuis une heure et là
y'a tout est gâté c'est pour ça qu'on
vous fait venir je me sens tellement
j'ai enfin la saleté manqué le sien tu
veux tu veux te présenter rapidement
commenté arriver ce stage que je suis
arrivé parce que parce que j'ai la
chance de connaître naveau est quand
même un peu bien
te disent ils ont quand même ben oui non
mais c'est vrai qu'il faut connaître des
gens parce que c'est c'est cool il m'a
envoyé un texto en disant ça te dirait
de
chômage est absolument
pas été là non sinon j'allais justement
dire c'est aussi parce que tu as du
talent que tu es là alors voilà je suis
là on ne sait pas comme ça d'habitude
entre nous et c'est vrai c'est une piste
non mais on continue et on va parler la
bouche pleine d'accord ferme et j'ai une
question d'une deuxième question de drax
haider qui demandent est ce que la
totalité des membres de votre équipe
demande la totalité des membres de votre
esprit comme ça at elle eu une formation
pro ou appris sur le terrain
moi j'ai ma femme et un bal salsa l'idée
camping
ils éditent l'envers c'est vrai tu es
vraiment combien dj combien de patine je
mixe à 4 platines le casting était déjà
annoncé claude françois ghislain mix
place vous pouvez y aller
sa vague la personne qui écoute et à ma
famille que pour moi-même quand même moi
d'essayer ces nombres d'années que je
connais écoutez ce sont même les femmes
et ça j'y réponds non sinon une réponse
sérieuse ou es ce que vous avez suivi
une formation spécialisée où vous avez
après sur le terrain pour tout ce qui
est humain ou technique réalisation
4 on a tellement le point commun c'est
comment on fait de la scène oui donc
déjà on avait peut-être une base après
c'est vrai que c'est différent d'être
sur scène et d'être devant une caméra
mais je pense déjà qu'on avait des
dribbles la rythmique en fait
sur scène cité quand tu écris un truc
est culte est sur la scène c'est comme
au grattage français le banco c'était ça
marche ou ça ne marche pas ta réponse
tout de suite en vidéo on se tressent
vachement plus parce qu'on ne sait pas
comment ça va être perçue c'est un peu
nouveau pour nous mais leur et on sait
ce que ça va rires du public tout de
suite mais on sait à peu près comment se
construit une vanne et commence et où
elle peut être un peu plus forte ou
moins forte dans sa construction dans la
façon de le faire même si c'est
exactement m ban et obtient je parle
super bien même ce serait trop fier une
phrase aussi on peut citer la prochaine
question alors je vous remercie d'avoir
enchaîné là dessus directement non
mais c'est intéressant la différence
entre le stand up et la vidéo mais du
coup vous continuez vous les 2 stand up
et vidéo à part vous ne passez pas de
l'ain fois non non non
non parce que en fait j'ai je suis
beaucoup moins expérimenté que hakim
antoine et greg et du coup je suis
encore dans l'école du bide en fait donc
c'est ouais une formation m c'est sans
mesurer en fait c'est un épisode inédit
de ken le survivant en vrai en vrai
c'est yacine belhousse qui parle souvent
de sa est dit que pour faire ce métier
il faut faire l'école du bide et moi
j'en suis encore et j'avoue que j'en
première année je suis en première année
mais ouais
voilà mais la première à l'hybride et si
les rentes viagères pendant les moissons
mention possible c'est quand même un bon
gros bide pour progresser dans la cij
est vrai que c'est génial je suis dacc
en médecine c'est la première année la
plus dure ouais mais voilà pour
l'instant je me suis fait bizuté pendant
six mois et donc on m'a proposé de faire
ça chez golden moustache et je vais
foncer dedans ça colle très bien et donc
là je suis à l'école du vide de golden
goose h maintenant mes
copains
de promo c'est un humoriste mais ça fait
un peu on n'est pas des m'as pas réparer
des bases fatah c'est un peu débile on
essaye d'être on est dans un univers où
j'habitais à côté
je pense que c'est d'ailleurs c'est à
dire moi je vais être un professionnel
de la blague je trouve ça un peu con
faux faux faux juste goulard être ou la
ferme ariégeois racontant des histoires
mais pas se dire que c'est être
professionnel pas
non mais j'ai envie dire pour détendre
un peu l'atmosphère on va accueillir
cette dernière était avec nous tous ont
fait flaubert qui nous rejoint robert
et si je venais ici
prévu que je vienne je devais être trop
en retard était alors fait je suis juste
très en retard ça va tu es ce que tu es
croyant notre ma vie je suis très
content je m'attendais pas du tout à ça
c'est grand et c'est télévisée mais
c'est joli c'est je leur ai été super
mais c'est usant on n'a pas enlevé les
films
encore le fictionnaire ça vient d'être
le petit boulot alors flaubert ça va ça
va être posé la question mais c'est une
question interne ouais ça va ça c'est un
petit jeu là que va rigoler ce que je te
rapprocher d'antoine s'il te dit dans
l'oreillette non ces questions des
internautes la crainte c'est lolo du 9 2
qui lui demande c'est à une réponse soit
la question est ce que tu as suivi une
formation spéciale ou non mais j'ai
suivi une formation nul j'ai fait une
fac de siné qui était marrante parce
qu'il y avait des gens marrant et que
j'avais accès à des logiciels de montage
mais j'ai pas appris grand chose mais
j'ai maté des films russes des années 20
pesos du cool mais c'est pas une
formation qui va me conseiller ned les
gens les gens qui ont la meilleure
formation que cette histoire est salée
pour ce que tu veux faire quoi mais
faire des vidéos aller en formation
c'est tout ce qui est bts mais voilà moi
je n'ai pas fait ça saute ça s'en
ressent la qualité de mes vidéos qui
n'aime pas on n'aime pas quant à la
jarrie quoi j'attends de voir ce qui va
me permettre de déchoir j'attends
tranquillement ça qu'il a fait l'école
du porno c'est que même en autrui ce
soit ça
s'est fait petit on a pitié pour toi je
crois que ça y est c'est ridicule allez
la soirée à tous j'étais vraiment trop
petit et du coup je suis très content de
voir remettre encore à côté 9
moi j'essaie de faire ce que je peux
juste ça va très bien
je suis bien très coquette donc une en
pâte de conseils particuliers il ya
c'est une question pour vous tous
l'oncle sim qui demandent donc le sim
qui demandent quel est votre vidéo
galles des moustaches favorite mais
origine une piqûre un peu bizarre et
ouais un peu compliqué comme question
mais c'est le but face à faire sucer
boulmé cosmos le dernier mois il m'a mis
par terre ces derniers pour le dernier à
l'avant dernier mais elle s mosman il
pas ouais j'ai j'en avais les larmes aux
yeux
moi c'était supérieur aux laboureurs
braquer une foule de raisons mais je la
trouve géniale vraiment pas de raison
particulière parce qu'à laisser les
jambes pour tout ce que tu dis [__] je
viens de l'écrire voilà la ville sur la
lune c'est ça qui est à mon avis
ce qu'il m'a dit oui c'est ça voilà
passé
je pense sos retard parce que je suis
souvent en retard et je m'étais toujours
dire il faudrait un truc qu'ils soient
là ma place mais je ne l'avais jamais
écrit en mode marrant et c'est très très
bien j'étais surpris par la chute en
fait je vais j'accorde beaucoup
d'importance à la chute si ça me
surprend non mais c'est les yeux en
disant
non mais c'est lâche c'est à dire que
comme je passe mes journées à écrire des
vannes pour la scène et tout ça quand je
veux voir des spectacles la plupart du
temps quand le mec commence une phrase
ou un thème je vois la chute venir et du
coup je rigole pas et quand la chute me
surprend pas pour moi c'est réussi le
but de donc voilà ça ça m'a surpris j'ai
trouvé ça cool mais d'ailleurs comme
vous faites tous de l'humour ça change
votre vision des blagues en général de
l'humour de ce que vous voyez vous avez
un autre notre approche ont souvent
tuerie par le d'études non alors que tu
devrais rires en fait ce que disent
et c'est très juste c'est qui fait pas
bon et alors que tu sais que c'est très
marrant avec c'est vraiment drôle mais
je suis toujours à la recherche je me
remets toujours comme un gamin de 12 ans
qui attend la blague on descendait tout
plus j'aime bien voir moi c'est plus
chaleureux en fait des clashs et
la série medal et 2h à achat sa reste
pas un rêve enfantin on est à dire que
pour écrire le rire il faut h1h1 et pas
assez
si tu veux tu ris pas en faisant moi je
préfère la là tu joues si on attend son
avis lui ferais tu es venu pour ça
jamais l'homme jamais de la vie s'il
vous plaît je me sens utile et lol c'est
écrit en grand bassin non moi je trouve
ça raciste que tu viens dire qu'est ce
que lol je sais très bien où tu veux en
venir l'équipe a
donc appelé pitot quelqu'un d'autre
voulez peut-être se prononcer sur la
meilleure vidéo pour ramasser par la
menace pas la meilleure vidéo celle qui
m'a fait venir sur la chaîne c'est la
vie c'est la vie sexuelle des jeux vidéo
parce que pour le coup j'ai géré
pas que avec le nez en fait et il y
avait déçu vraiment des deux très bonnes
idées notamment la vanne de metal gear
solid j'ai beaucoup je crois que c'est
la foire oui c'est ça ouais oh là là là
je t'arrête selongey sinon tu m'as fait
rire tu me que quoique que notre
approche un tout petit peu de graisse
des zones oui bien sûr mais c'est
coacher en fait ce
choix-là
meubles jonglage
et d'en parler en réunion des fois enfin
vu qu'on a dit plein de fois la chute on
se rend plus compte si c'est vraiment
drôle ou pas et du coup on se demande
juste si est-ce que c'est mal alors au
lieu de se demander est ce que c'est
drôle ça t'arrive yens en plusieurs fois
moi moi je le préfère ça en fait je
préfère que les gens se un souvenir de
la vidéo en disant ah [__] c'était
bien vu que tu vois c'était à c'était
cool ça m'a marqué tu vois sur internet
à 38 vidéos marrantes par semaine en
france voilà si tu prends le monde et
tous les jours tu as une vie
d'aujourd'hui oui j'ai bossé avant de
venir mais avec 54 truc comme ça non
mais du coup moi j'aime bien me dire ah
[__] je que cette vidéo quand les gens
ils ont fini de la mater s'en
souviennent après où selon eux deux
choses et pour répondre à ta question
sur mes vidéos préférées
on a plein moi j'aime vachement ou
versus life 1 et 2 les princes charmants
j'ai vraiment kiffé cette vidéo je pense
que même pour le coup peut-être ma
préférée est
bon c'est moi qui l'ait fait mais avec
mes copains non mais
c'est leur droit qui les fait sur le
coup on l'a vraiment fait avec suricates
c'était la musique radio parce que
j'étais trop fière qu'elle est bien
marché et que les gens soient mariés
enfin moi c'est pour moi c'était on
savait qu'on est inclus et jeux vidéo
les gens allez cliquer mais on est
vraiment un super tour et c'était la
première fois rafa vu ça avec
l'adhésion mais moi c'est la première
fois que je participe à une vidéo qui
cartonnait aux états unis pakistanais
qui marchait un peu aux états unis et
qui fait du coup on avait un public
américain qui sait trop bien qu'on était
sur nine gags et tout ce qui bouge pour
moi donc
voilà j'en garde un souvenir ému et
justement sur tes vidéos est ce que tu
vas faire des vidéos comme le bureau des
rêves ou syndrome post rupture qui était
un peu plus
mélodramatique
alors lancez-vous lancé jeudi c'est ça
que tu vas maître du piano la prochaine
vidéo c'est la question ça
dégoûte c'est tellement non mais
c'est pas ma volonté de faire des vidéos
mais aux dramatiques comme tu dis même
si fait que je sais pas trop c'est des
trucs un peu tristoune mais c'est quand
même très bon je trouve enfin les
comédiens qui font les trucs sont très
marrant dedans donc non c'est juste par
contre j'aime bien format un peu courts
métrages ça je le kiffe bien et
j'aimerais en faire d'autres et voilà
c'est plus des mini films ou des bois
des petits courts métrages mais c'est
pas la volonté de mettre des trucs mais
aux dramatiques comme tu dis qui vient
récemment d'être une mère est c'était
manger je suis plusieurs fois on m'a
empêché de te suicider dans une
baignoire il ya andrew besser qui
demande qu'est ce que vous auriez fait
comme métier si vous n'étiez pas rentrer
dans golden moustache et
bien vous faites tous du stand up à côté
sa mission était plus tard vraiment le
métier que tu aurais voulu faire la
banque et pompiers devaient porter de
paris ouais vraiment chaude à rebours de
vrais corps humains des connards
j'ai un master nas et lui sa
relaxation j'ai un master en marketing
elle est bilingue en pole dance mais
mais je les fais parce que je ne pouvais
pas faire confié
joaquim c'est le chapitre 2 mais ça
me suis fait opérer en fait avant mais
là ça t'a fait de l'humour tu préfères
tu sais pas je sais que je vais avoir
des jambes
lagré j'ai toujours voulu faire de
l'humour mais je suis j'ai grand méchant
à pied non j'ai grandi au havre pour moi
ça me paraissait impossible de venir à
paris de d'essayer de monter sur scène
j'avais aucune idée de comment vous êtes
non mais j'avais aucune idée de comment
on commençait ça me paraissait pas
faisable en fait du coup je disais non
mais arrête tes conneries de rêver
choisir un taf que tu peux réellement
faire et leur et de votre mail et de
valider grâce à ces
professionnels
oui parce que
j'ai réussi rien
physiquement là ça se voit pas il ya
beaucoup de questions tout neuf
il ya futé gt gt un très bon tennisman à
l'époque d'après ben j'ai découvert les
fast-foods tout ça et j'ai laissé tomber
le tsg une dernière question et après on
va faire rentrer tout le monde je vous
laisse avec quelqu'un demande c'est
guillaume laurant qui demandent combien
êtes-vous lors d'un tournage et
peut-être que flaubert qui réalise aussi
répandues que ça marche
on est plus gros qu'au début on a plus
de gens
non mais
l'équipe mais ces couches d'eau tempe
alors on a une équipe trop cool bon
allez on a des noms équipe trop cool qui
revient souvent je cède la faute non à
une équipe trop cool qui revient souvent
et avec qui on se marre beaucoup et ce
qui est très cool en plus c'est qu'on
les partage un peu avec studio beagle
enfin c'est des gens qui tombent maman
dans la fiction vidéo
je vais pas dire si
on a faim on a plein de gens vraiment
cool qui bossent sur les vidéos de plein
de gens sur internet et
et on a la chance ou est d'avoir chez
fog preneur son maquillage mentale par
montage pour le coup c'est moi qui le
fais mais on peut avoir des gens tu vois
on a des joueurs et fixi france ait eu
ou fin donc ouais non mais on a une
vraie équipe et souvent c'est les mêmes
et ses goûts c'est vraiment super
mortels superman un enchaînement de
moquer un peu de piquant même merci
beaucoup flaubert merci à vous on va
faire rentrer tout le monde c'est bon
ils peuvent rentrer merci à tous si mal
mais
je pourrais
garder les bonnes questions juge quand
je suis parti à
la mecque et ben merci beaucoup d'avoir
suivi ce live merci à brainsonic de nous
avoir accueillis times et merci à tous
d'avoir est venu
à peine croyable je suis dépressif et je
sais absolument pas quand ça se termine
nous voilà on peut faire
comprendre que la réponse
merci à diamou défi encore
terminée c'est terminé c'est oui merci